Reuters reported exclusively on Sunday that Google's parent company Alphabet...
...has suspended some business with Huawei, a major blow  to the Chinese tech giant...
...that the US government has sought to blacklist around the world.
A source close to the matter told Reuters...
...that business requiring the transfer of hardware and software products,...
...except those covered by open source licenses, is suspended,...
...though details of the specific services were still being discussed internally at Google.
The suspension means Huawei will immediately lose access...
...to updates to the Android operating system,...
...and the next version of its smartphones outside of China...
...will also lose access to popular applications and services...
...including the Google Play Store and Gmail.
Last week, the Trump administration officially added Huawei to the trade blacklist,...
...immediately enacting restrictions that will make it extremely difficult for Huawei...
...to do business with US companies.
But on Friday, the US Commerce Department told Reuters...
...that it may soon scale back restrictions on Huawei,...
...saying it's considering temporary licenses for the Chinese company's existing clients.
The US believes Huawei's smartphones and network equipment...
...could be used by China to spy on Americans.
Huawei has repeatedly denied those allegations.
The Google suspension comes...
...as China strikes a more aggressive tone in its trade war with the United States...
...and Beijing has suggested that a resumption in talks will be meaningless...
...unless Washington changed course.